What catches my eye is
I truly feel that I am most touched by
work that has some sort of connection to
nature.
It is about the biomorphic even
zoomorphic if you want to be fanciful
tendencies of a certain piece and,
and,
and I've always found that I am a less,
of a hardcore modernist and more of an
organic surrealist modernist in terms of
my own taste and my own passion and what
I go for and when I'm trying to develop
new areas of a market with,
with my team when we're kind of saying,
you know,
something,
this Danish cabinet maker or Moose,
there's only been two of his works to
ever appear in America.
Wouldn't it be great to like talk to
some folks and see if we can find more
of his work and bring it out.
It always seems to fall into that
organic kind of,
um,
aura for me.
You know,
you definitely,
mine
certainly.